weekend and happy Monday welcome to the
posit Enterprise Community Meetup
that is my first time saying that in
case you haven't heard yet last
Wednesday our studio became posit and
I'll share that blog post on the
announcement it looks like there was
more than our usual few second delay
here so let me restart all of that but
hi everybody hope you had a great
weekend happy Monday welcome to the
posit Enterprise Community Meetup and as
I just said that is I guess now my
second time saying that in case you
haven't heard yet last Wednesday our
studio became posit I'll share a blog
post on that announcement if you didn't
see it I'll put it in the chat here in
just a second but if you just join now
feel free to say hi through the chat
window and maybe where you're calling in
from
special welcome to you if this is your
first time joining us for this Meetup
today this is a friendly and open Meetup
environment for teams to share use cases
teach lessons learned and just meet each
other and ask questions these normally
happen on Tuesdays at 12 Eastern Time
posit has a holiday tomorrow so we moved
it to to today but I will share a link
in the chat where you can also find out
about other upcoming events too
together we're all dedicated to making
this space inclusive and open for
everyone no matter your experience
industry or background
during the event we'll take a few breaks
for questions and have time for Q a at
the end too
so you can ask questions on YouTube live
if you're watching over there but also
anonymously through slido
which I'll share in a few seconds in the
chat but let me just put this on the
screen for you here this is where you
can ask questions anonymously too to
address one question up front yes the
recording will be available and it will
be actually be ready right as the
presentation ends at the same YouTube
live link
today I am really looking forward to
learning more about data science and
people analytics well I personally don't
come from an HR or people Ops background
I have had the opportunity to hear a lot
more about this recently at our Thursday
data science Hangouts and it's actually
where I first met our speaker for today
Liz essro
a few months ago on the data science
hangout with Dave and Meza at Nasa we
were talking about people analytics to
get to the moon and there were a bunch
of comments and interests about sharing
more work done in the people analytics
space and learning more about this space
so here we are today thank you all so
much for joining us today I'm very
excited to introduce our speaker
Elizabeth essarov Elizabeth is a data
scientist in people analytics at at T in
her role Elizabeth is part of a larger
team focused on embedding data and
analytics into the root of decision
making and transforming insights into
actionable solutions that improve
employee outcomes and drive business
value and so with all of that thank you
Liz I will pull you up here on the stage
with me and pull your screen
thank you for joining us Liz can you
hear me okay yes I can okay perfect
Rachel
I will head backstage but I'll be in the
background uh pulling together questions
and I'll come jump back in here and in a
few minutes thanks Liz okay and I will
pause periodically for questions as we
go along so feel free to post them and
Rachel feel free to interrupt me if you
have some questions about a slide I'm
displaying so that I can stop and answer
that while it's on the screen
and I thought I'd introduce myself a
little and tell you uh something about
my background here
I've been a data scientist at ATT for
about six years focused on people
analytics partly due to my background in
Human Resources I've been in HR for 20
years in various analytics-based roles
and several years ago I started seeing
that many companies are beginning to use
predictive models in HR so I went back
to school to get a master's degree in
data science and have been applying data
science techniques at at T ever since
if you have any questions about this
presentation afterwards feel free to
reach out and connect with me on
LinkedIn and I'll be happy to answer
them
we're going to start by talking a little
bit about people analytics for those of
you who may not be familiar with this
field and then we're going to go into
three different areas where we've found
data science techniques to be very
helpful for us in people analytics at at
T one of those is using predictive
models to reduce employee attrition
using time series forecasting for
Workforce changes and analyzing employee
survey comments
so to start with a little about people
analytics we started several years ago
in ATT in HR analytics where we were
measuring a lot of the HR processes and
techniques to Monitor and improve those
areas within the company then we
expanded our data analysis into
Workforce analytics where we are
measuring patterns in our Workforce data
and all in with the goal of informing
decision making and improving
performance
now we've cast a wider net on the data
that we're analyzing in people analytics
and where we're including not only
Workforce data but we're also including
business data and behavioral data and
outside research occasionally to help
Drive insights improve performance and
solve business problems
we found three areas of opportunity for
data science in people and analytics one
is regarding employee retention where
we've used predictive models to
determine professional and personal
characteristics associated with a high
probability of leading the company so
that we can change policies and help
improve retention
we've also found time series models to
be very helpful in supplementing our
strategic workforce planning needs
and like many companies we have employee
surveys where we ask employees to give
us feedback about at T and in those
cases we've found text analytics more
specifically topic modeling and
sentiment analysis to be very helpful in
summarizing thousands of comments that
we receive from our employees
any questions before I move on
I think we're good for right now okay I
will let you know once we have some
popping in and just a reminder to
everyone you can ask the questions
either in the YouTube chat and I'll see
them or on slido where you can ask
anonymously too
okay one area of high interest in many
companies is how can we use predictive
models to help reduce employee attrition
and if you're not familiar with the term
attrition that is a metric that we use
in HR to measure the rate at which
employees are leading the company
we have three main turnover categories
that we look at and which you also might
want to look at at your company in terms
of determining which areas you might
want to focus on for your first
attrition project
one is involuntary dismissals the other
could be voluntary
separations or voluntary turnover that
is related to retirement and we could
also have voluntary turnover that is not
related to retirement where those
employees instead of leaving the
workforce they are leaving the company
to go work somewhere else
and we found it very helpful in looking
at our attrition projects to also look
at different employee segments and
choose the ones that are appropriate for
your company but we found helpful to
look at Frontline employees who work
directly with our customers knowledge
workers and Executives or senior
leadership
for each of these groups then we
consider the degree of difficulty of the
project versus the potential benefit we
may realize in terms of return on
investment from achieved from reducing
an attrition
for employees that voluntarily leave due
to retirement meaning they're leaving
the workforce and aren't planning to go
to work for another company the degree
of difficulty in reducing attrition is
fairly low however the potential benefit
is low to medium due to this being a
smaller percentage of our employees
however when you're looking at voluntary
this attrition that's not related to
retirement for Frontline employees the
degree of difficulty is about medium
it's higher than those for retirements
but your return on investment is very
high
with Executives or senior leadership the
degree of difficulty is higher than
those for Frontline workers and your
return on investment or potential
benefit is lower simply due to this
being a smaller population of our
Workforce
and with knowledge workers your duty of
difficulty is higher than those for
Frontline employees but your potential
benefit is also just as high as you'll
see with Frontline employees
for those that are involuntarily
dismissed your degree of difficulty is
higher
and your potential benefit is low
because this is typically a very small
percentage of the population
as you're continuing to plan a attrition
project we have a project road map that
we found very helpful in consisting of
four steps our overall goal is to
identify the items that we can change
and work with leadership in the business
unit to help Implement those changes
with the overall objective of reducing
attrition
so our first step is identifying those
areas of the business unit where we have
high turnover and also a good return on
investment if we can reduce attrition
we then conducted research and developed
predictive models to identify what those
nutrition drivers are
then developed interventions on the
variables that we can impact or change
in the business unit and we selected
certain locations where we implemented
those change changes and then over time
we measured the impact to attrition for
those locations to see how much impact
we could achieve if we implemented them
Nationwide and from there we chose which
items we wanted to change and roll them
out throughout the entire country or
throughout the entire business unit
whichever is applicable to your company
in developing a project for focus on
attrition it's also very helpful to
segment your employee population to help
control for any latent variables and
some areas that you might want to
consider looking at could include
employee tenure were you trying to
figure out where is your higher
attrition rates is that found among new
employees or more established employees
you may look at management status
non-management versus management
employees perhaps looking at supervisors
versus individual contributors and see
where you might have the most impact
job type is a key one we're grouping
similar jobs together helps minimize the
impact of latent variables for example
our technicians who are working in the
field maintaining our Network are doing
a very different job from say our sales
associates and retail stores doing
separate attrition projects focus on
each of these job groups separately
helps us make sure we're getting good
results from our predictive models to
determine what are the attrition drivers
for each of those job groups
and you might also consider looking at
results of your employee engagement
surveys to see how attitudes impact your
willingness to stay
and just like job type you might also
consider full-time versus part-time or
if you have shift work at your company
consider that as well grouping those
different types of employees together
may also help improve any attrition
project or predictive models that you
are building
any questions before I move on
I'm seeing quite a few questions
starting to come through on slido and
let me jump over there were a few about
kpis and one was what are the most
important people analytics kpis at at T
oh we have several in depending on what
are the needs of the business we develop
them but the one focused here in this
case for an attrition project is there
is a standard attrition kpi that all
companies measure in HR and that is the
number of employees that separate
divided by your average head count for a
specific time period that you are
measuring and that will give you you
multiply that result by 100 and that
will give you an attrition rate we
always express it as a percentage
and if you're looking at tenure groups
you may look at your number of employees
who separated in that specific tenure
group divided by your average head count
in that 10-year group to get a more
specific measurement for each of the
tenure groups that you're looking at for
example
thank you another question maybe I'll
take three questions or so right right
here but one was
um do you distinguish between attrition
versus turnover based on the position
being backfilled or not
most of the time we measure attrition in
terms of whether it's involuntary or
voluntary meaning the employee chose to
resign and are either going elsewhere or
perhaps if they're voluntary and they're
also retiring and we know that for a
fact we might look at attrition just for
those that are not retiring but we don't
measure it in terms of whether or not
we're backfilling the position in that
in the attrition calculation itself we
don't
great thank you
um there was one other question I see
that just came in on YouTube and I'll
pull that up on the screen but Paul
asked can you share how your team HR
acts on these predictions
um both experimentally and ethically do
you implement new policy in smaller
groups
I will get to that on my future slides
okay yes our goal is to change policies
to try and improve attrition
perfect thank you
um we'll get back into the presentation
and then we can stop in a little bit for
a few more questions too okay thanks Liz
okay so uh some of you may be wondering
what are some of the potential inputs
that we might consider including in a
predictive model that's focused on
attrition
and we've grouped these here in terms of
professional personal attainment
attitude and other items that you might
consider so some items and these aren't
specific to ATT these could apply to any
company so you could include job titles
I mentioned grouping similar job titles
together
uh Department locations full-time versus
part-time for example among personal
characteristics if you have the data you
can consider education level of
employees their tenure any information
about their career path within the
company for example commute distance
for attainment look at performance
information that you have if you have
customer satisfaction scores for
specific jobs where that is measured you
couldn't consider including that or any
job specific performance metrics that
are unique to the particular job that
you are measuring for your current
project
um under attitude you could look at
engagement survey results or onboarding
surveys if you have those in your
company
and for other items you might even
consider local unemployment rates to see
how that might be impacting your
attrition rates and supervisor
performance metrics if you have those
easily available
there are also factors that we
specifically don't model and we work
very closely with our legal counsel and
our privacy team to determine what items
are appropriate to include in our
predictive models and that could be from
a standpoint of the legal perspective as
well as an Ethics perspective to comply
with at t standards regarding what we
consider appropriate to include in our
models
any questions about this
um I don't think there's questions
specifically about this so I might hold
them till the end as well
so
um many of you may be wondering about
the predictive modeling techniques and I
would encourage you to work closely with
a data scientist we consider this to be
a partnership between HR and the data
scientists in my case I'm a data
scientist who's in HR but I also work
closely with HR business partners and
business unit leaders to try and get a
good understanding of what items they
think might be affecting attrition as
I'm developing input for my models but
then we go into the predictive modeling
techniques so if you are an HR person
and you are working with a data
scientist this is where they will get
more heavily into the technical side of
things we've used several different
types of machine learning models and we
test different ones to see which ones
are the most accurate we are
specifically focusing in this type of
case a class on classification models
where we are trying to predict a binary
outcome of did the employee stay or did
they leave based on all of the
historical data that we've gathered of
employees who stayed and left in the
past and controlling for all of the
things that are included in that model
together in one place we can then
interpret the results of those models
and determine which items are associated
with a high probability of me
high probability of leading the company
compared to other items in that model so
interpretation of the model for those of
you who are data scientists you may be
familiar some models are more easily
interpreted than others
in people analytics interpretation of
the model is the most important
and here's an example of why it's most
important because when you are later
communicating with Business Leaders on
the results of that model they want to
know which variables are associated with
high probability of leaving as well as
which ones are associated with our
ability to influence or change those
items and this type of visual is just
one possible example of how you may
present that data to leadership to let
them know which areas that we might want
to focus on where we're going to get a
high return on investment for making
those changes
are there any questions about predictive
modeling for attrition
okay another area where we found very
helpful is forecasting Workforce changes
and for this types of forecasting we
have been using time series predictive
models if you're not familiar with time
series models these are models where you
are measuring something over a period of
time this graph on the right side of the
page will give you an example not
specific to ATT but just to show you
when you're looking at time series
models oftentimes you have to consider
whether there's any seasonality in the
data so you can see on this example
there's an increase in value around the
beginning of every year and the
predictive part of our model which is
shaded in blue is also forecasting an
increase at the beginning of each year
so this is the type of model that we
have found very helpful on some cases
for workforce planning one area that
we've used this often is estimating the
pandem makes impact on our Workforce in
2020 and 2021 as each variant of the
coveted virus spread throughout the U.S
we were able to make rough estimates of
employee absences that we might see in
different Geographic areas and that
helped us ensure that we could do some
planning maybe even temporarily moving
employees to other locations to help
ensure that our customer needs continued
to be met during the pandemic
we've also found changes like many
companies employee attrition rates have
been very different in both 2020 2021
even throughout this year and we've been
using some models to try and predict our
future changes in employee attrition
weights that we might see which then fed
into our strategic strategic Talent
acquisition plans to try and determine
how we needed to change or backfill
positions as people left
and our third area that we found this
very helpful is in our future planning
as our plans for our product portfolio
changes over the next few years we've
been using models to try and predict how
our Workforce may change in the future
both through voluntary separations or
employees moving into other job titles
in order to give us a feel for how we
may plan for skills and job titles that
may be needed in the future
are there any questions about time
series models yes sorry Liz I didn't
know I was muted before but I was saying
what I was saying was there's a lot of
great questions but I was trying to
figure out which were most relevant to
this section but there was a question
that is
um how have you validated the predictive
models looking backwards how precise
were they
uh I don't remember exact numbers on how
precise are they I typically test in
terms of Time series models I test two
or three different algorithms and I
choose we use um if you're not familiar
with predictive modeling we divide our
historical data into a training set and
a test set and we will use one set to
train the model and then we test the
predictions on new data that has not
been seen by the model yet and that's
where we measure the accuracy of those
models but I don't remember any
specifics on how accurate they are
okay
thank you another question a bit earlier
was
um do you work with and I'm guessing
that This Acronym is HR business
partners but do you work with your HR
business partners to segment your
population
yes we do and we also if sometimes HR
business partners will bring in the
business unit leaders and for those of
you that aren't familiar in HR business
partner serves as alien it's on between
the business unit and HR they are often
the most informed about the current
business needs of each of the business
units that they work with and so they've
been very helpful in working closely
with us to help us identify areas that
we might focus on to improve the
business
thank you for the definition there too
that's really helpful
um I see one other question and then
I'll let you get back to the slides here
is
um what languages were used in building
your predictive models
I build my models in R I'm not primarily
an R programmer we have other team
members that build their models in
Python so we we aren't exclusive to one
particular language
thank you I'll hold some other questions
to the end too okay
so our last area where we found data
science to be very helpful is analyzing
employee survey comments and I mentioned
in our surveys we sometimes ask
employees to give us feedback about ATT
where they're allowed to type anything
that they would like to say and when of
course you're looking at thousands of
comments it's hard to summarize what are
people talking about so we found topic
modeling to be very helpful in this area
the modeling approach that we use for
those of you that are familiar with text
analytics is Leighton Dairy clay
allocation
and this allows us without going into
the math in a lot of detail this allows
us to group together certain comments
based on the keywords that employees use
in those comments we take out some of
the common words like the and of because
every comment is going to have those
words in them and that then reduces down
the comments to the unique words that
exist in each of them
from there we can then summarize those
topics so here's an example of how topic
modeling may work yeah and this is just
based on industry data because we figure
most companies are going to see comments
about these topics
so you can see here on the left I've got
two lists of words here and these are
examples of coming comments words that
are coming from various comments from
employees and you can see there's two
entirely different lists advancement
opportunity career promotion is entirely
different from pay retirement salary
raises and insurance and so forth so
from there we can then decide our topic
for the items on the left are more
focused on Career growth and these items
on the right are focused more on pay and
benefits related comments
from there we can continue this process
to label all of our different topics
that show up in the comments and that
can then allows us to prepare some
summaries for executives to let them
know which areas are people commenting
on the most what are the biggest
concerns of our employees and from there
they can decide what actions they want
to take to try and change things at a t
based on the feedback that we've
received
another area in text analytics that we
found very helpful is we often get
questions from management regarding the
sentiment of those topics or the
comments in general are they positive or
negative
so in that case we've been using
lexicon-based algorithms there are two
general purpose lexicons available in
both R and python one is a fan and Bing
and these are developed by researchers
who have examined a lot of comments and
determined that certain words are
representing a positive or negative
sentiment in those words or in those
comments
however for people analytics cases where
employees are commenting about their
jobs or Awards or benefits we found it
helpful to customize these lexicons to
give us a better understanding of the
sentiment Express in work related
comments or job-related comments so
we've removed some words from the
standard lexicons and those words are
listed here on the left
and you can see things like pay and work
they're they're more General topics of
comments about paying work but what we
really want to know is what is their
sentiment about pay and work for example
so we found it's easier to remove those
words and then we can get a better more
accurate understanding of the sentiment
of their comments and then you may find
looking at the comments in general you
may find there's words that should be
added maybe even some that are unique to
your company or your industry that would
help give you even better understanding
of sentiment and some words that don't
exist in the general purpose lexicons
like burnout we're seeing a lot of
articles about employees feeling burnout
these days micromanage which seems to
exist in almost any company these are
things that you may consider adding to
your custom sentiment lexicon to help
give you a better understanding of your
sentiment in these employee-based
comments
what we do overall in sentiment analysis
is then from that once you've customized
your Lexicon we apply that to the
comments and try and measure the number
of positive words and the number of
negative words that appear in each
comment and we take the positive words
minus the negative words and give us any
general comment score so that we can see
overall is that comment mostly positive
or is it mostly negative and from there
you can give management and
understanding of are the comments about
a specific topic more positive or
negative or even just overall among all
of the comments that employees to make
are they mostly positive or negative
are there any questions about tax
analytics or anything else that I've
talked to talked about it previously
there are a lot of great questions
um
one question was
do you Heather ask do you use
demographics like age ethnicity and
gender to predict attrition
we work closely with our legal and
privacy team to determine whether it's
appropriate and what cases it might be
appropriate to include those so I would
recommend that you also do the same at
your company before putting them in your
model
okay
and another question was are your survey
results attributed to employees
um or are they anonymous
they're Anonymous but we have the
ability to try and group the data so
that we know in general for different
types of groups of employees what are
the results that we are seeing
thank you and um another question which
I think also touches on when you were
talking about presenting to leadership
but how would you get the ROI from HR
attrition modeling
we work closely with our finance
department to determine the cost of
attrition or the cost of replacing a new
employee and from there we can then
determine how much would it cost to
replace that employee based on our
attrition or how much we would how much
savings we would realize if we can
reduce the rate at which we need to
replace employees
great thank you and I'll save some more
of the questions for the end here but
judging by all the great questions it
seems like we should continue having uh
many more people analytics chats too
okay well actually that is the end of my
presentation so if we don't have other
questions feel free to let me know
great thank you so much Liz
um yes there are tons of questions here
so let me let me try and organize myself
here for a second and pull a few of them
up
um a few questions
were kind of centered around like how to
get into
um people analytics and maybe what kinds
of backgrounds people might come from
one question was uh are most of the data
scientists there from a psychometrics
background or Are there specific classes
or courses you'd recommend
uh oh boy that's there's a lot of
different ways we could go
um we on our team since data analysis
skills are extremely important we've had
people who join us that had data
analytics skills from other parts of the
company we we tend to hire internally or
post our job openings internally before
going outside of the atnt so that's why
I mentioned the people that have joined
us either have data analytics skills
from other parts of the company and they
come into the people analytics team or
they have a background in HR with strong
data analysis skills and they've decided
to specialize in people analytics which
is the path that I took and we also have
data scientists who've come from other
parts of the company and decided to come
join us and specialize more in people
Analytics
as far as learning the people analytics
side
um there are some courses on LinkedIn
learning to help get you familiar with
the general field of people analytics
and some of the HR metrics that are
commonly measured and I there was an
excellent book Rachel I think I gave you
information about excellence in people
Analytics
which is recently published and it will
give you a very good overview to help
you get familiar with people analytics
there's lots of example use cases in
that book to help you understand
different areas that other companies
have use people analytics and data
science techniques even predictive
modeling to help improve the business
awesome yeah and I put I put that book
recommendation into the chat I tried to
show it here on the screen but it's a
bit long it might what I wrote in the
chat but
awesome let's see so
I really I love this question too is is
there a kind of critical mass to apply
people analytics is it just for big
companies or do you see a lot of small
companies with people analytics teams
too
I think small companies can use people
analytics too they may find that
predictive modeling
might work better if you have a large
employee data set but there's a lot that
you can do with statistical analysis
and
um if in fact there's a book by Keith
McNulty that provides several examples
of other ways that employees could or
people analytics teams could apply
regression modeling and other
statistical techniques to help solve
business problems and that can apply at
a large company or a small company
I'll show that book recommendation on
the screen here for just a second but I
also put it into the chat
lots of great questions here so let's
let's see
um Alex asked on YouTube do neural
network modeling methods have a place in
people Analytics
I have not used them much however we're
open to trying anything if if it works
and you can interpret the results
thank you and in what you are just
showing on like the positive and
negative comments do you quote verbatim
comments in your reports for example
like here's one of the very positive or
very negative comments we receive
occasionally if it helps when we're
presenting results to leadership
sometimes it helps them to see more
specifics of the comments that employees
are sharing to get a feel for what are
they saying about a specific topic
thank you
that uh that slide there was making me
think about like the difference between
what someone's text might be in an
anonymous setting versus in like a
company meeting and if there's like a
different threshold for like negativity
versus positivity in those settings
like do you find that people are are
generally more negative if something's
anonymous
I don't know that we've measured what
they say in a meeting environment where
everybody knows everybody in order to be
able to have some solid data help answer
that question
thank you
I just want to jump over to some of the
questions on slido
and somebody asked do you use something
like snowflake to store and model your
data and do you deploy these models
automatically or manually update them
we haven't deployed any models in
production yet but we're working towards
that but at T does use snowflake in some
parts of the business
I'm throwing a lot of questions that you
hear like right another in a row so I'm
curious are there any questions that
you'd like to ask back out to the
audience here too
I can't think of anything
um one question I saw earlier was
um our user here how do you balance
between people Ops focused analytics
tools often very expensive but helpful
with custom analytics often time
consuming
and I'm not sure I understand I think
the difference between the two do you
mean custom analytics versus tools that
are developed by vendors
it's an anonymous question but I'm going
to try and and guess I think it's
uh yeah how do you balance between maybe
like proprietary software tools or
expensive like people Ops
tools
versus like probably code first or open
source data science with r python also
I'm guessing so if I am completely wrong
on interpreting let me know in in slido
too okay well um in many cases we start
with a cost benefit analysis and
determine how much would it cost to buy
that tool from a vendor for example
versus developing it in-house ourselves
for ATT we may be a unique company
because we already have a lot of
employees with excellent software
development tools or skills and we
already have data scientists working
throughout the company so developing
these items in-house sometimes it's more
cost effective for us but we also have
some cases where we found it's better to
work with a vendor so it just depends on
this specific situation
and I think that would be the same for
most companies is take a look at your
cost benefit analysis of what it would
cost to do you have the employees to
that have the skills that you need to
develop in-house tools
you know if you don't have those
employees what would it take for you to
hire them versus what would it take for
you to hire a vendor to have build
something for you
thank you
I see Heather had asked on slide out how
much of your work is driven by HR
leadership or HR Business Leaders or by
the HR analytics team pushing modeling
and insights to those groups
oh that's um I would say the majority of
our work since we are designed around
trying to solve business problems it's
usually based on requests that are
coming to us from the business unit
leaders they identify an area where they
would like us to do some analysis to
help answer questions for them or help
solve a problem for them and so I would
say that most of my work I don't have an
exact percentage but most of it's driven
by the business units and trying to
solve problems for them or provide
something of value to them we have very
few cases where we design the project
ourselves and then go to the business
unit
thank you
I had a question for like for people who
I'd be like just thinking about getting
into people analytics now and maybe work
on a people Ops Team like what was what
was your journey into learning data
science and
getting into people Analytics
um my particular journey I started in HR
many years ago based on the fact that I
had data analysis skills at another
company and I was not working in HR so
they hired me due to my data analytics
skills which back then was working
primarily with databases and building
reports using tools such as I think
Crystal Reports was one back then
and I've continued staying in HR because
I've always found the work fascinating
as our work evolved in terms of more and
more advanced analytics that we were
capable of doing here at ATT
um then several years ago I decided to
go back to school and get a data science
degree when I started seeing articles of
how other companies were using
Predictive Analytics to help solve
business problems and we decided we
wanted to do the same thing at ATT we
had some other team members that were
already starting to work in that area
and I just decided that would be my area
of specialty
in other cases we've had i o
psychologists who have worked with our
team and they come from the psychology
background but they also have a lot of
data analysis skills that they're
bringing to the team as well and
occasionally we've had data scientists
who have experience in other parts of
the company who have joined our team and
build up their skills and understand the
enough people Analytics
hey thank you I also just wanted to say
to everybody listening and I know
they're like there's so many awesome
questions here so if you are working in
HR analytics or people analytics and
you're part of different communities
centered around this I'd love to have
you share them in the chat as well if
you want to share them with other people
here or other upcoming events to I think
it'd just be helpful for us all to
share resources with each other too
um I see John had asked on YouTube do
you have a role in educating business
units as well to help improve their
questions for example
yes on our team we have a Consultants
that work closely with the HR business
partners and the business unit leaders
at the start of a project when we come
that there's
something that they have in mind that
they would like the people analytics
team's assistance with and they're so at
the start of the project we often
clearly meet with them to try and
clearly Define what exactly are the
business questions that they want to
answer what things may be feasible for
us to measure and help them solve and
and try and get more definition or scope
of that project
foreign thank you Liz for letting me
throw all these questions at you here uh
maybe we'll do five more questions does
that sound okay to you sure okay
um somebody had asked and I see it's one
of the most upvoted questions now on
slido what is the HR Tech stack at A T
does your team have a data engineer
solely for people data since it's more
sensitive
we have
um database administrators or some of
the roles that we have uh and I guess
that would also be considered data
engineers in in some companies we also
have software Engineers who develop some
proprietary tools for at T to assist us
with reporting in analytics and I
mentioned before we have Consultants who
work closely with our HR business
partners and business unit leaders to
help Define the projects and answer some
of those early questions that we get or
in the start of a project
and those Consultants continue working
with us throughout the project so they
may be meeting with us when we're
presenting the results as well
and um Advanced analytics team members
who are doing Advanced reporting we also
have a products team who's developing
reports and various tools such as power
bi and power apps whatever those tools
are the best ones that have fit the need
for the business those are the ones that
we choose to develop whether it's
something proprietary that's developed
in-house or if we can use something
that's already existing such as power bi
we may develop reports in in those tools
and then of course we have data
scientists who can do our more advanced
analytics projects predictive modeling
text analytics and so forth and project
managers to help us manage all of these
projects
great thank you I um while everybody's
here and so engaged I wanted to ask as
well a poll in the slido so I just asked
over there
quickly if we were to have another
people analytics Meetup is there a
specific topic that we covered today or
didn't that you'd like to dive deeper
into and would really appreciate your
your feedback and thoughts over there
too
and that's just on the the slido link
um but diving into some of the other
questions here
um I see Angel asked
how do you present your results is it an
application reports or PowerPoint
um how important is it to learn other
languages like JavaScript CSS or SQL
um presenting results can vary depending
on the situation so it could be in
PowerPoint on various reports or
internally within the applications some
of the proprietary applications that ATT
has developed and learning other
languages I would say SQL is commonly
used anytime we're pulling data from our
databases and so everybody on our team
is learning SQL or or already know SQL
um
I'm not sure if we have people that have
skills in JavaScript or css some of our
software developers of course are using
specific languages for software
development but I don't know what those
languages are
thank you
um okay I apologize if I missed some
questions here but I will try to gather
all of our questions and group them
together to make sure that they get
answered in in some way or another with
the recording too
um but another
question I saw
um uh see from novaldo was
if you were to start a people analytics
team right now in a company of maybe a
thousand people how would you start
oh that could take a very long time
maybe that's a whole separate talk yeah
that could be a whole separate
presentation
um I would recommend the Excellence in
people analytics book has some good
advice for teams that are just getting
started and also uh you may find the
authors are available on LinkedIn they
post blogs on a regular basis giving
recommendations for new leaders and um
that those may be the best places to
start unless we have a separate
presentation on how to start a people
analytics team
great thank you yeah and I just shared
the the book in the chat again here but
if there are other uh resources or
recommendations that you all have as
well feel free to share those and I can
try and collect them
um to put up with the recording too
okay
searching through
um for maybe two more questions here
um
okay one question was
around
um
internal tools for surveys let me copy
it over to the screen
do you use an internal tool for surveys
or do you do you use thresholds to
maintain a not anonymity it's a hard
word to say sometimes
um depending on the survey some of them
are managed by vendors to help keep that
and an anonymity for the employees and
some are developed internally within a t
so it's it's a mix of both for us
okay thank you
okay this is very hard to sort through
all these questions great questions
right now
um
let's see oh I did want to announce also
that
um
one upcoming people analytics talk I was
just thinking about is
um David Meza will be presenting on
NASA's use of analytics
um
in people analytics at the our
government event in DC this December
and I actually I actually have a 20 off
code that Lander analytics shared with
me to share with our community so if you
are interested in attending that
conference let me know
um do you want to reach out to me on on
LinkedIn I'll put my LinkedIn in the
chat here in just a second and I can
send that over to you
okay one one last question Liz and we
can ask this to everybody uh here as
well to share is
do you have any favorite R packages for
people Analytics
ah I have many favorite hard packages
um and I I think it may not be unique to
me to people analytics but the player is
probably one of the ones I use the most
just for rearranging my data and doing
exploratory data analysis
um oh I wish I can remember there are a
few that I have recently learned about
that are also very good for exploratory
data analysis to summarize the data in
different ways and I cannot remember the
name of them
but I also use a lot of the packages
that are in the Tidy verse and then for
text analytics there are separate
packages that are specific to the Tidy
verse but kind of applying the Tidy
verse Concepts to text and they are
mentioned in a book on by Julia sild and
I can't remember the name of the other
offer but it it's all about using the
Tidy verse for text analytics Rachel I
think I gave you a link to that one and
it's available for free on the web yes
but he is interested in getting into
text analytics copying that one over
right now and into the chat and just
showed it here on on the screen too
thank you okay I'm sorry I said one last
question but there's so many great
questions coming back here one one more
okay does at D have remote workers if so
does people analytics segment on remote
versus hybrid versus on-site
ah good question and one that's coming
up quite often in in many companies or
considering remote workers so yes we do
have remote workers I for one am a
remote worker
um we had remote workers prior to covid
and for those of you that aren't
familiar with HR the whole concept of
remote versus office has become a big
debate after covet as many companies are
discussing whether or not to have
employees return to the office full-time
or have a hybrid schedule so we have
changed our policies we now have
full-time remote workers we also have
hybrid workers and we have employees who
work on site some of that is determined
by the type of job they do obviously
technicians working remote is going to
be difficult and some of it just depends
on the employee's personal preference
there are some people who prefer to be
in the office and like that environment
working in person with others and some
who prefer working remote
and it varies throughout the company
thank you so much Liz for sharing your
experience with us but also answering so
many awesome questions shared here by
everybody I know I
unfortunately I don't think I got to
every question here so I want to do my
best to look at all the questions gather
them and maybe we come up with some sort
of like
follow-up blog posts and get more of the
people analytics Community together as
well okay thank you so much Liz sounds
like we have a lot of interest in this
topic a ton of Interest yes
um I also wanted to extend an invite to
everybody here today if you haven't been
to data science hangout before we have
those every Thursday at noon eastern
time and we feature different data
science leader from the community
in a very informal setting to answer
questions that you all have whether
that's
maybe how somebody is using people
analytics or how they're thinking about
hiring and growing their team all the
questions are up to you and would love
to see you in in that space too that's
actually where Liz and I met and got to
talk a bit more about this topic so I'm
going to put the link in the chat right
now if you want to add that to your
calendar too
but thank you again Liz really
appreciate your time today and and all
your insights thank you all for the
great questions too yes thank you and
thank you Rachel for inviting me and
thank you everybody for taking time out
of your schedule to join us today
absolutely and I will end with what John
said here there's a real HR analytics
Revolution coming and
thank you all again have a great rest
today